you my friend the first thing you said
to me when I sat down was oh my god you
look like somebody I arrested before
dude I've known you for like two minutes
I don't even know your name apparently
people are a lot braver than I am so you
know are they're a lot more comfortable
with their stories I'm just more excited
to be here and to share stories hear
everybody else's story for me more so
it's uh in our situations that you're
kind of conditioned like you guys are
the enemy you know I don't know how you
guys feel about us or you know I've
never had a deeper conversation with law
enforcement probably from your point of
view is is that it doesn't always seem
like the justice system is fair I think
that what you find though it's if you
truly love this job and this work that
you strive to find that balance in
fairness I I'm puzzled by what he's
saying because I've never heard anything
like this before because I mean if it's
true what you're saying then how come
police aren't policing police why are
you standing idly by while your fellow
officers are going around shooting and
killing unarmed black people why is that
happening
I sold drugs that's why I did I sold a
[ __ ] ton of drugs and I didn't have
family I never you know I mean I grew up
in foster homes I I didn't have any type
of family but I [ __ ] knew that when I
went to prison I knew I didn't want to
come back to this [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying so while I was in prison I knew I
needed to start there and build a
foundation I've been out of trouble
since 1999 you know so I chose to give
in my own crimes when I was younger I
wanted to violence I could have easily
chose to do something else but I was
always there when things were gonna
happen I was talking about thinking
about between my professional life or my
personal life I think that like you know
it's it's one of those things where like
you look at for instance have I have I
killed anybody have I robbed anybody
have I like all these major felonies now
have I have I sped before yeah
absolutely you know what I hear is uh
you're telling me there's levels of
legality I mean I used to be sort of on
that and to like I grew up well I went
to private schools I mean I'm not
somebody you know like which stereotype
as somebody who gone to prison you know
and then I've gone to prison and I just
find out how [ __ ] up the system is I
mean what about that guy who goes out
has dinner and has a drink ends up
spending seven or eight years in prison
because somebody started a fight with
them but then I meet people in prison
who shot somebody in the back of the
head execution style and only got ten
years for it you know whereas for me I
spent 13 years in prison because
somebody was hurting my family I thought
like okay well we're gonna go get our
stuff back from this person and I get
conspiracy to commit robbery conspiracy
to you know use a gun which has added
another 10 years and it's nothing ever
happened
you know nobody got hurt and like maybe
it's cultural maybe it's you know I grew
up where like you defend your family you
know and yeah like was it a bad mistake
sure can
ask the question they're like why your
first thought wasn't like let me call
the cops to help solve this issue cuz
you know it like from my experience
growing up cops don't help they just
come by show up make a great show of
doing their jobs and then leave but I'm
just saying there's no consistency in
the system it makes no sense it depends
on which county you go to which judge
you show up in front of it's a political
game it's that's not justice what would
you consider justice to be I mean I
would like to see that you know there
would be some consistency if I go to LA
County or San Diego or wherever that the
same crimes that carry the same time
there would be some you know
consideration for you know situation I
don't think there is the criminal
justice system truly does help to
protect societies if we did not have it
that there would be chaos well it may
not be perfect right now but we need the
justice system and we have to believe it
for some reason it just seems to me that
if you're from a wealthier family you're
easy to get off the hook when I was
fighting my case I had a sulli
who was fighting the same crime that I
committed for an attempted murder he had
came back said that the judge gave him
one year with two strikes I don't know
how that went about but for me i end up
getting ten years with one strike and
his family was wealthy in that did you
have priors did he have priors
I had no priors I didn't understand why
is it that you know if your family has
more money it's easier to get off the
hook a lot of times I I saw that if you
have a private attorney
high-power attorney I guess you have a
better chance of getting off than having
public defender that could be a little
hole in the criminal justice system but
that's how it is right now and then I
don't know how to address that issue so
I guess that's it shouldn't be a game it
shouldn't be a game with people's lives
like how how can I get this when how can
I negotiate a win with this person's
life at the end of the day man it's all
about
and it's about numbers and there's no
there's no money in rehabilitation man
there's money in recidivism money and if
I could give up my job today as a result
of no other people going to jail which
means that they would actually stop
committing crimes I would do it in a
heart oh yeah but there's not too many
people like you if we had a system guys
like you awesome I think that that's
that's but again see what you just said
is that's the perception that you have
is that there are no it's not it's a
reality for us for me when I was inside
and the nonprofit that I worked for we
had you know the programs in there and
this is a class that are is gonna help
them you know actually do something with
their lives every evening while the guys
are going to class like they get
harassed and they we come out of the
class and all the cops are lined up and
like get on the wall strip-searched
tear up textbooks tear up their personal
property their their homework like yeah
that's how the system is like on the way
out of prison officers were telling me
like I'll see you back on the next one
you know like that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of everybody in the circle that he
was the first one to actually voice the
fact that he made choices it's in that
moment that they claim dominion over
themselves so I appreciate that thank
you I don't know how they feel about
that I don't think any one of us right
here sat here and say like I didn't make
my own choices I understand I made my
own choice I got myself my own time I
thought yeah I get the sense that you do
too I think the larger issue is that the
system is broken and that's what I have
a problem with I don't have a problem
with taking ownership of my actions it's
society not taking ownership of its own
creation and I hope you don't hear that
he was the one he was the only person of
course local and say yeah I will ask you
this so and I'll challenge you do you
know who your representative is - have
you ever contacted their office no have
you ever contacted your Congress member
no then I suggest that you should I mean
I okay and here's the thing cuz you
strike me as a very smart individual
that has the ability to go in influence
I agree with you
as I just think that you need to take a
walk in our shoes you know like and I
don't mean any disrespect by this but
you sound like an a law enforcement
pamphlet you know like you sound like
every perfect thing that they want you
to say it's kind of like when you work
in a company and the CEO says this is
the policy but when you're on the ground
level you know that there are certain
things that just doesn't work in reality
I think you have you know great views
and I think your if we had you know long
like just a team of law enforcement
there's exactly like you to even I have
the same views like it would be great
you know but I also think that there is
reality when you come out of prison
everything is just so stacked against
you like it seems that that's that
commonality so like when a friend since
when I talked about coming out of
military I had people that told me when
and where to be all these rules and
regulations and when I got out you know
there was nobody there same thing
happens in prison you have to break out
of the prison mind mentality
here's difference between the mill and I
agree with you there's a lot of
similarities there are a lot of
commonalities with prison in the
military however when you're in the
military
you're told you're the men of this
country are the defenders of this
country you're men then you go to prison
we were told that we're pieces of [ __ ]
we were told that we're animals you know
and when you've gone through a decade of
that it it gets in your head inside your
mind it's like Who am I like Who am I to
think that I can do these things it just
turns you into nothing you know and it
makes you believe that you're nothing
that you can do it and that's something
that you can't put into you know LAPD
policy you know and that's what the
justice system does to you like it
breaks you but you know what I can tell
you this me looking at you I don't see
any of the things that you that you talk
about I would hope for you for actually
all three of you think you know that you
guys are able to to escape those those
boundaries that have been created
because guess what at the end of the day
like you have one life to live and it's
going to be predicated upon the
decisions that you make now
[Music]
I honestly believe that they have a
structure in place that can help the
people who are running it are the ones
that need adjusting I think it needs a
lot of work I think the resources are
put in to a lot of the wrong places and
I'm not okay with saying well this is
what we got so let's try to work with it
like no I think that there should be
moves to try to improve the system like
I don't think we should ever be content
you know like I said unfortunately when
the budget crisis happens training is
the first one that goes out the door I
think they need more training if they're
training said the one life I think is
worth it I also think communication to
build a unity in the community that way
that it can be trusted with one another
and be able to to work with one another
with all the challenges that's going on
in this chaotic world
conversation what you have any
information on your not bra I do
actually
hey guys much appreciation we get to do
what we love because you all watch our
videos so if you really love us you'll
continue to keep watching videos there's
more right here that you can check out
you probably haven't seen all of them
and if you really want to just commit to
us you can subscribe right here I'll be
around I'll be at the end of some more
videos and I will keep in touch
peace